there is growing desperation among
Indonesians who survived the devastating
earthquake and tsunami the death toll
has risen to more than 1400 recovery and
rescue efforts are intensifying across
the island of Sulawesi last night
President Trump spoke with Indonesia's
president and offered to send aid Ventre
sea is in the middle of the disaster
zone in pallu Indonesia then good
morning as if things could get any worse
here a volcano erupted on this very same
Island today now authorities say so for
that does not require any sort of
evacuations but even the threat of that
has added insult to considerable injury
this is where the tsunamis nearly 20
foot high wall of water hit Pulu barely
anything is left standing
[Applause]
the water also destroyed something that
can never be rebuilt all dyani lost five
of her family members including her
father and mother and those
I love you I'm ready I love him the
search for the dead continues both with
big machines and bare hands
shortly after we arrived these rescue
workers found two more victims they told
us one was the body of a 12 year old boy
aid is not arriving fast enough and
basic supplies are quickly running out
so we were just driving by this gas
station and we saw this hundreds of
people are camped out here with their
gas cans hoping to get them filled up at
the front of the line was this man named
Ari
he sat here through the night only to
find out there won't be any fuel
arriving today how hard is it to live in
this town right now it's house the sheer
scale of this disaster seems more
overwhelming as the days go by what do
you want people who are watching this in
the United States or other places to
know about what's happening here
we need to help least people from all
around but on the way people here are
starting to get angry about how the
Indonesian government is handling the
response to this disaster but one piece
of good news the Red Cross tells us that
a ship full of supplies should arrive
here on Friday for CBS this morning Ben
Tracy
haloo Indonesia all right then Ben thank
you very much I won't forget that
woman's words I very very love them you
know you see the story in the news do
you think the earthquake but then you
see the devastation that then the toll
it takes on people and having covered
these in the past the pictures never do
the justice was the scale of what has
happened what we just all have lost it
was a very very tough story